hi I'm Gordon bandicam the executive
producer for war of the vikings and
we're here at the pdx pond and miami
florida so what we're about to play is
conquest game mode it's a little bit
different than a contemporary when you
think of from first-person shooters
where there's meant multiple control
points what ours is objective based so
what you're going to do is this one
you're just going to try and capture and
control points and push I'll you know
control all the control points and it's
in a linear progression so I've joined
the squad everybody's joined green wolf
but I'll join red moves with a teammate
because you want to be in a squad with
other players because one of the key
things that you can do while you're in a
squad is you can actually target your
enemies and that makes it easier for
your squad mates kind of find a guy
especially if archers really want to
point them out so if you an archer on
your squad that they start plucking off
the other archers for you so as you can
see stone house is that is the first
objective now in this map it's actually
only four control points but on other
map sirs can be odd number so there's
usually five but in this one is one of
the few ones where you can typically do
a draw you're gonna have a drawn out
somebody saw have my shield get hit by a
fire arrow fire arrows actually go out
when they hit you as a player but what
they are for is that the only arrow that
can actually destroy that'll destroy a
shield somebody just did their tongue
and I killed him so
they've capturing the tubbin sorry I got
a little quiet because I'm kind of
getting into personal confrontation to
the government sphere now the sphere is
really hard to use you should typically
use your sphere only if you were if
you're trying to you want to use the
spear if you have a partner like you
have somebody with a shield and you can
get behind them and you can actually use
that over their shield so a shield in
our game exists only in that space so if
the players can get around your shield
they can attack around it so it's not an
ultimate defense with a you know like
with a force field so right now I'm
primarily focusing on my custom kit but
next time I spawn and i'm going to jump
onto the other kids and kind of explain
what they're doing and will kind of like
what their purpose is there really
general all-around flag class class load
outs that just really kind of highlight
the character so it's really good for
everyone to pick so maybe you created a
custom profiles not working out how you
wanted it to you can always default back
to those days and they're in no way
inferior kissed then just don't look as
cool typically in their bit different
looking so right there what I did was I
finished off the opponent so your
opponent's typically just get knocked
down but what you want to do is and you
want to finish them off so that they can
get revived back in so all players can
be revived by their teammates as well so
and that gives you a lot of hit points
and it's really a good there's oh I got
a special to the face but you really
want to try and revive any teammates
that are fallen it gives you a lot of XP
points and it's something that's really
useful so the default warrior so this
kids just an all around what you would
think of a normal Viking sword and board
medium character he's got the shield and
he has a throwing axe as a secondary
weapon he's really really really just
all-around effective you he's really
easy class to do really really well with
so he's really
good the good default use the one that
you'll start with that oops I ax say and
we also have friendly fire on so you can
kill your own teammate so you have to
really be careful you want to try and
use different attack so you want to use
the upward swing when you're near your
teammate sir but it's harder to hit your
opponent with but it's also less likely
to hit your teammate or objects in the
world so your your sword can hit barrels
it can expenses and hit everything so
the whole world is like you know it can
be an obstacle for your combat so you
really want to take the right moves no
that was a nice solid hit he wasn't
wearing a hood I would have got addie
cap on him but the hood actually catches
your head so there's a lot of physics in
this game and a lot of things that we do
it's all you know ladies all physics
pace so it's like it's a living world so
I mean of course there are some things
it is a game so not everything is
perfect but you know we try to really
keep things going in that sense where's
like what you would expect to happen
should happen you shouldn't be faked or
you know given the advantage by the game
yeah and next is the default champion
now this is a bit more tricky class to
use we're actually debating whether we
want to release with this in a second
class is you have to prepare you don't
have a shield you don't have any default
kits but it is a really powerful weapon
so he made the mistake he missed with it
another cool thing is you can loop
weapons so you see this weapon
highlighting so I could actually switch
to that weapon and make that my new
primary but I want to make it my
secondary so I'll switch to my secondary
daggers and I'll switch to that and make
it my secondary so now I have like a
different melee weapon in but no
throwing weapon that's okay because I
can also pick up a shield so I can kind
of design my kill this guy i can take
his shield
there we go and decapitated it and now I
took the shield now I switch to my
Signori so I can kind of create a kit so
even if maybe a weapon that you picked
is not something that you really ended
up liking you can kind of augment that
while you're playing kind of change it
around yeah that's the special for the
one hand it up well thanks for watching
this guy's I really appreciate you
checking our video out all the way
through to the end really appreciate it
just one a quick reminder that we've
actually were alive right now in Spain
and early access and this update just
went live so if you want to get your
hands on it early and help us you know
shake the final aspects of this game
we'd love to have you join and we really
appreciate it and thanks for checking
out war of the vikings
you